hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be delving
into the latest events
that just took place in the black clover
story
we just learned the real name and
identity
of asta's anti-magic devil we also
learned his tragic origins
and it was pretty much confirmed that
the woman from the devil's memories
is none other than osta's mother oh and
we also know her real name now
and so much more this was one of the
best chapters
in black clover i absolutely loved it
so let's get into it if you enjoy our
black clover videos and you want to see
more please leave that like
it really does help and if you're new to
animal pro
or you just haven't subscribed yet make
this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications remember you really
have to go through the trouble of
hitting that bell
and then also selecting the option that
says all if you don't do that you're
still gonna miss a lot of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
and of course this video will contain
black clover manga spoilers we are
talking about the latest crazy reveals
in the story so please proceed with
caution you have been warned
by the way as soon as the leaks for this
latest chapter came out my brother goes
and i
went live on our twitch to discuss them
hundreds of people joined us as we
looked at those crazy leaks and as we
absolutely fangirled over all the
amazing revelations
so if you're interested in talking about
the latest chapters as soon as the leaks
drop
live with us and this means before we
even publish the video here
on the channel definitely follow us on
twitch twitch.tv slash
anime uproar or just click the top link
in the description
okay so at the end of the previous
chapter we saw asta's devil
think back to his memories with a woman
who looked a lot like
osta osta reminded the devil of this
woman
because just like him she had told the
devil that being a devil doesn't make
him a bad guy
the latest chapter dives right into the
devil's tragic backstory
and it gives us some important
information about the
underworld the world where the devils
come from
this chapter pretty much confirms that
the devils are not humans who became
corrupted by forbidden magic which is a
possibility that i talked about in my
previous video
rather devils are their own unique
species
and they are born in a very dark and
ugly place
known as the underworld as soon as a
devil is born
his place in society is settled and
there is no way to change it
it seems that the status of a devil is
determined by how much mana they possess
and since the anti-magic devil was born
without mana
he was considered to be the lowest of
the low and here we already see some
parallels between the underworld
and the human world but since the
underworld is extremely
boring the higher ranked devils spend
their time
terrorizing those devils who happen to
be below them
and since the anti-magic devil was on
the lowest tier
he was bullied and abused every single
day of his life
to be honest this description of the
underworld reminds me a lot of the
shinigami realm from
death note just like the shinigami the
devils are constantly bored
and their biggest thrill in life is to
try to toy with
humans every devil's goal is to find a
way
into the human world so that they can
possess humans
wreak havoc and stop being so bored all
the time
however for a devil to be able to enter
the human world
they need to make contact with a human
and they need to convince that human to
make a contract
with them this is not an easy thing to
do and it doesn't happen often
but one day while he was being bullied
by the other devils
the anti-magic devil was thrown at the
gate that separates the underworld from
the human world
the anti-magic devil fully expected to
hit the gate and get
smashed to pieces but because he had no
magic
he was able to actually pass through the
gate and
into the human world in the world of
black clover
the underworld appears to be a realm
that is literally beneath
the human world and so we see the
anti-magic devil getting thrown
upwards and then he emerges from the
ground into the human world
it also seems that this gate between the
worlds has some sort of magic spell
attached to it this spell blocks
everyone with mana from entering the
human world from the underworld
and potentially vice versa but then
since the anti-magic devil has no
magic he was not blocked from passing
through the gate
and so he achieved something that the
other devils thought
impossible he entered the human world
without ever forming a contract
with a human but even though he was now
free from the abuse of the other devils
the anti-magic devil didn't fare much
better in the human world
he was already so traumatized and
exhausted that he didn't even care about
the humans
he had no desire to toy with them or
possess them or manipulate them
in any way but even though he was just a
broken kid with no
evil intentions he was still feared and
hated by the humans
just for being a devil as soon as they
saw him they wanted to call the magic
knights to get rid of him because they
assumed that every devil was the same
they were all evil and dangerous at some
point the anti-magic devil was chased
down by humans with powerful magic
until he had no more strength left in
him somewhere deep in the woods he
collapsed and he made his
peace with the fact that he was about to
die he didn't even feel bad about it he
was ready for his miserable life to end
but then something surprising happened
instead of dying
the anti-magic devil woke up inside
someone's home
a human woman the same woman from the
last chapter the one that looks like
osta had found him passed out in the
woods taken him in
and nursed him back to health this woman
introduces herself as lychita a word
that means permissible
or allowable in latin lychita explains
that her magic
allows her to essentially seal anything
that doesn't have mana
inside a small object such as a little
bottle
it seems that while she was out
gathering firewood she came across the
anti-magic devil
and so she smuggled him into her home by
hiding both him
and the firewood inside the little
bottle this is actually a pretty useful
ability when you think about it
she can secretly transport large objects
and even people as long as they don't
have mana
lycheeta would make a great spy or like
a construction worker
the anti-magic devil is surprised that
lichita is being so nice to him and that
she's not afraid of him
but the woman says that she has no
reason to be scared of an
injured little kid and she can also tell
that the devil has no magic so she knows
that despite his devilish appearance
the devil is not dangerous lichita then
reveals two important things
about herself first she reveals that
just the other day she found
and took possession of a five five-leaf
grimoire
she says that the old superstition about
a devil residing within the fifth leaf
must be true since just after finding
the grimoire
she came across a devil lychita also
reveals the true nature of her
own magic her body steals magic
and life force from everything around
her and this appears to include
humans plants and animals lychita
doesn't seem to be able to turn this
ability off
so she is forced to live on her own in
the middle of nowhere
presumably she is also an outcast who is
feared and hated by her fellow humans
because of the true nature of her magic
so in that sense lichita is uniquely
capable of understanding the life of the
anti-magic devil it seems that because
the anti-magic devil is a devil
and not human and because he doesn't
have any magic
he is able to be around lychita without
suffering any adverse consequences
lichita is convinced that this is fate
and she asks the devil to stay with her
and become
her kid the devil is shocked to hear
this at first
but as time goes by we see him slowly
warming up to lychita
and then eventually fully accepting her
as his mother
we got a beautiful page of the manga
that shows the two of them
bonding and becoming a real family we
also see that the devil is slowly
growing and becoming stronger i feel
like this one page in the manga is gonna
end up being like a whole episode in the
anime and you know what
i actually don't mind i absolutely love
this
we then see the very moment in which
lichita tells the anti-magic devil that
being a devil doesn't necessarily make
him a bad guy
and it is clear that he himself is not a
bad guy
lichita then reveals the devil's real
name for the first time
his name is liba which means love
in german and i have to say i really
love
this moment in the chapter not gonna lie
it brought
tears to my eyes because it is clear
that not only did lichita save liba
but liba also saved her he
saved her from always being lonely and
on her own this was truly powerful and
beautiful
but then unfortunately this emotional
moment is interrupted by a terrible
tragedy lucifero aka lucifer
the devil who is believed to be the
strongest of all suddenly tries to take
possession of leva's body
lucifer is surprised that a devil has
been able to stay inside the human world
without ever making a contract with a
human
and so lucifer wants to take over liba's
body so that he can find a way to
manifest his own body
into this world but lichita refuses to
let
that happen she uses her magic to absorb
lucifer's magic
and essentially force him out of liba
normally
lichita couldn't do anything to someone
as powerful as lucifer
but because he is possessing liba inside
the human world without a host of his
own
lucifer is nearly powerless at this
point in time
lichita is definitely aware of the
danger that she is putting herself
in but she loves liba as much as her own
son
and she refuses to let lucifer hurt him
in fact
we then see a brief flashback to a time
when lichita
seemingly dropped something off in a
basket
on the doorstep of a stone building and
as we see this lichita vows that this
time
she is not letting go in the very next
moment we see lucifer piercing through
lichita's torso with his demonic arm
as she screams that this boy is
not yours lucifer continues his attack
but ultimately he is thwarted by
lychita's magic
and he is forced to leave liba alone
at least for now nevertheless lucifer
vows to return
and attack liba again in the future
as she bleeds from her wound lichita
embraces liba
and apologizes for not being able to
completely protect him from lucifer
the only way that she can protect him
now is by using her magic to seal liba
inside that five-leaf grimoire in the
hopes that by the time he
one day emerges from the grimoire liba
will be strong enough to resist lucifer
and defeat him as she seemingly dies
from her wound
lichita says live liba my dear
son liba then calls her his mom as
he is sealed away inside the grimoire
for his
own safety back in the present moment
the furious liba says that he will never
forgive the devils
despite being a devil himself he says
that devils are scum
every last one of them and he vows to
kill them all
even if he has to steal asta's body to
do it
and that is how this phenomenal chapter
ends
and i was honestly left in awe after
reading this
chapter so amazing so many great reveals
so much emotion and drama
and now we know who the anti-magic devil
really is and
what drives him we now know why he was
so angry at dante and lucifer in
particular
back when he and austin were fighting
against them and that is just one small
part of everything that we've learned
just freaking amazing first off i want
to say that i almost
missed that little detail about lichita
leaving a basket
outside a stone building as she says
this time i'm not
letting go thankfully multiple people in
our twitch stream noticed this right
away and pointed it out to us
so yeah thank you guys so much for that
and to me
it is clear that this scene is showing
lychita giving up her first son
asta at the orphanage in hagee village
sometime before
she met liba my guess is that lichita
decided to give up her son
because she wanted him to have a normal
life and also because her magic
might have actually hurt him if he
stayed with her
she obviously deeply regretted that she
had to make that decision
and when she met liba she saw him as a
second chance for her to raise a son
after being forced to give up asta this
makes
liba the anti-magic devil asta's brother
not by blood of course but they both had
the same mother
she was osta's birth mother and liba's
adoptive mother
now we know that asta was also born
without magic just like liba
and in fact there are many parallels
between the two of them i wonder if asta
was born without magic because
lichita's body drained his magic when he
was in her womb or if foster was born
without magic for some other reason like
maybe his father didn't have magic
and he inherited this trait we actually
still have no idea who
asta's father was or how he was able to
even become involved with lychita if her
body drains the magic and life force of
other people
all we know now is that the anti-magic
devil definitely
isn't osta's father and that reminds me
according to this chapter lichita's body
not only drains the magic but also
the life force of other living creatures
we know that henry suffers from a curse
that makes him drain the mana of other
people
in his immediate area which is
definitely similar to lychita
but it seems that lichita's condition is
even more severe
because she doesn't only drain mana but
life force as well
if lichita only absorbed the mana of
others and asta was born without magic
then presumably she could have let him
stay with her safely
but if she also absorbs life force then
asta would have still been in danger if
lychita had kept him with her
and so if that's true it makes sense why
she felt that she had to give him
up to the orphanage the other
interesting thing that i want to talk
about is the five
leaf grimoire it seems that because
zagred
never ended up taking possession of this
grimoire after creating it
it remained empty after the elf massacre
at some point lichita found it and then
used it to seal away liba
in order to protect him and presumably
this happened before sakran located the
grimoire again
after awakening in her anti-bird form
everything
is finally coming together and now that
we've talked about this
awesome and heartbreaking origin story
for both liba
and lychita we need to talk about what
this means for the present
liba doesn't seem to realize that asta
is leachita's son
asta clearly reminds him of her but
since she gave osta
up before he ever met her liba doesn't
realize that asta is essentially his
adoptive
brother as a result liba is prepared to
use
osta and even take over his body in
order to get his revenge on lucifer but
once liba inevitably learns that asta is
lichita's biological son i think that
his approach
is definitely going to change instead of
trying to use asta as a tool
he is going to work together with asta
and both of them are going to fight to
honor the memory
of their mother i honestly can't wait to
see that happen
long lost brothers coming together to
defeat dante and lucifer
and save the world such freaking hype
man i can't believe how many parallels
we have between the lives of
asta and liba both were born as outcasts
without magic
both of them defied the odds and became
strong
both were the sons of the same woman and
now they're both
linked and fighting together after all
these years
i'm probably gonna have to make a whole
video talking about this relationship
between austin liba because it's so
fascinating i'm sure there's going to be
a lot of tension between them at first
and i'm sure there's going to be drama
but at the end of the day these reveals
will just bring asta and liba closer
together
and make them a stronger team in the
long run let me know what you guys think
this might have been my favorite chapter
in all of
black clover do you guys agree let me
know
down below also how do you feel about
the origin stories of lychita and liba
and did you like the twist that asta and
his devil are actually
adoptive brothers even though they don't
seem to know it yet
finally it turns out that we still don't
know anything about asta's father
so who do you think he was was he just a
random guy who was maybe born without
magic
or was he someone more special and more
importantly
is he still alive definitely include
your feedback down in the comments below
don't forget to follow us on twitch to
join our live discussions on the latest
leaks and reveals
twitch.tv slash anime opera or just
click the top
link in the description if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
black clover content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know it really does help
and if you're new to anime pro or you
just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications remember that you have
to go through the trouble of clicking
that bell and selecting the option that
says all
if you don't do it youtube is still
gonna bury a lot of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
it works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar a big thank you to all
of our
anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and
liam thompson
disciples of lord tuigo himself and i
can't forget our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans
including ingrata the world acquired
respect
pate heffa jonathan king wrathween deora
red haired raven emperor otaku thomas
jones kin mano admirath
and chris torley finally thank you to
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
steelers anatoly kazatsky cricket xp joe
stanton
very gucci jessica calefon alicia octor
hinokami and water
bonnie parks florian joanne garcia
mcshamus deadly saint and high school
dxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you